a fund to fight youth crime this Sports
Group has been awarded a share of a
brand new funding pot which the
government hopes will keep kids busy and
off the streets the idea is that uh for
those young people who might be at risk
of getting drawn into anti-social
Behavior or even worse things like drugs
and gowns we give them by supporting
support like boxing and football which
you're seeing behind me a positive
outlet
the Deputy Prime Minister was in
Tottenham a part of London with a
particularly high crime rate co-founder
of the sport and mentoring charity
through life Michael Donaldson welcomes
the cash injection but wants to see
politicians dig deep more often I think
politicians try their best to understand
I'd love to see him actually spend uh
rather than you know five or ten minutes
an actual calm down and be part of a
program come and do a week with us I
know it's difficult but I'm yet to see
any way to do it I don't understand why
statistics from sport England show that
most young people are getting active
again now the pandemic is over but their
figures also reveal that youngsters from
the most deprived areas have been slower
to get back to playing sport there is a
different path former footballer and
through life Ambassador JB mcanuff says
that needs to change you see it might be
just the enjoyment they're getting the
smiles on their faces and again a lot of
children are coming from you know
difficult situations at home possibly
you know we've seen kids who are not
perform particularly well in school but
by being able to come here and it gives
them a little bit of an incentive to
sort of right we're gonna have to
knuckle down a little bit at school you
know a little bit of a focus you know
somewhere that they can come and they
want to come
youth crime costs the UK 1.5 billion
pounds a year so the government is
hoping this funding will lessen the blow
to the taxpayer but with few
opportunities for vulnerable children in
communities like these this is just one
small step on the road to safer streets
Aurora Sky News Tottenham